Finney your word is champagne I'm so
ready to show that Kenny is not just
brawn but he's a whole lot of brains as
well CH a MP a and GE well things went
obviously uh BAC bad for Kenny medicine
exclusive peek at that ice episode of
The Bachelorette and we've talked a lot
about how much drinking is evolved and
Bachelor franchise because of the
Paradise scandal well
booze is definitely a big part of this
game I was kind of a little suspicious
because they were bringing out a lot of
shots kind of really quickly sounds like
I'm feeling that we're gonna get off
this boat and have to do something up
here so that's how you start a
Bachelorette Spelling Bee a bunch of
dudes on a booze cruise shot back in
March on Hilton Head Island South
Carolina Rachel brought 13 of her
remaining 15 guys on this date we were
testing the brains portion today
definitely separated the good spellers
from the bad spellers because some of
the words were a little racy the kid
judges actually put on ear muffs get a
word wrong go to detention where a
server was waiting with more drinks and
with four cameras 20 producers and more
than 75 extras on the five-hour shoot
yeah that totally spells romance to us
at this point who are your three
frontrunners so I don't know come on I
don't know it is so hard for me to
narrow it down to three Rachel may be
playing coy but there was no denying the
sparks between her and Peter
check out that adoring look and her
smile when he was on stage
how would you describe your feelings
towards her your attraction to her at
this point with Rachel is instant
connection it was easy to fall for real
quick
but while Peter is falling for Rachel it
seems the guys have been making some
connections up their own there's a huge
bromance going on in the house right now
and they are so nice and sweet to each
other and very respectful yeah I would
say right now as of now so gentlemen's
game it's actually surprisingly we're
all here for the same reasons and I
couldn't tell you a villain I think the
biggest issue is that all of us are very
concerned about our hair so we've been
hounding the producers left and right to
get us barbers to come in and cut our
hair we just something that they're not
really used to
[Music]
you